da dove iniziamo signora suo figlio non
mi ha preso nemmeno una sufficienza
dall'inizio dell'anno dove se solo se
applicassi un attimo dovrebbe anche dei
bei risultati ma non si applica non
gliene frega niente figlio non smette un
attimo di chiacchierare e questo
influisce poi anche sulla condotta di
Grimaldi e Raffaelli demoni potete
andare avanti
perché chiacchiera e lui inizia a
chiacchierare con qualcun altro Io ho
spostato vicino ai termosifoni ha
iniziato a parlare da solo anche con
loro a loro hanno spostato vicino alla
lavagna mi giro Cosa faccio facendo Tik
Tok Tik Tok nella mia lezione capisce
che la situazione diventata gestibile eh
Cioè mi limite è tutto bravissimo nelle
altre materie non mi risulta proprio ma
controlliamo questi purezza Allora
francese 2 inglese 3 educazione fisica 4
4 educazione fisica signora è veramente
grave cosa dobbiamo fare signora me lo
dico a lei me lo dica lei no io i
miracoli non li faccio i miracoli gli fa
solo la Madonna se continua con suo
figlio Non solo mi ripeteranno ma non si
riproverà mai più lei è la madre lei sa
fa cosa serve fanno a inserire Grazie a
lei ci mancherebbe quella alla porta
Prego prego